you've got these two unfortunately named
siblings and they're making shirts okay
Joe is like me he's a bit slow okay it
takes his time but but he's quite
accurate he's got a 98% floor of
Australia okay only two percent of the
shots he ever makes our defense Fay is
faster she's a whole 50% faster okay but
she makes twice as many errors as Joe
does so four percent of the shirts that
she makes on any given day they are
defense ok so then here comes the
question what they do is they bundle up
all of the shirts they make they bundle
them into boxes of 30 ok at they go 30
each well obviously they're gonna do
more than one a day but each box that
goes out to the warehouse is 30 shows so
the question is what is the probability
right that no more than two shirts in
the box no more than two shirts in the
box
our defense right so I would write it
like this
because you know if there's more than
two shirts if there's three or four or
five shirts in there that are bad you
know the company's going to send it back
and say this is rubbish you must be
joking forget it anyway so we want to
think about so last one I have to make a
way through um we want to think about
what's the Pope how likely given this
kind of error rate right how likely are
we to get under this threshold what's
the probability that no more than two
shirts will be defective okay now the
first big clue is okay this is a
binomial probability question this is a
good candidate you don't have to do a
bunch binomial probability but it's a
good candidate for it
okay because you know you have 30 shirts
do you really want to draw a probability
treat for all 30 shirts probably not
okay but then how do you you've got a
phrase of the right way don't you okay
it's it's multistage that's easy okay
it's got has got it two outcomes you can
probably think about what the two
outcomes will be but because they're
both in the situation it makes a little
more tricky so why is this harder then a
normal binomial probability question
okay I'll tell you what let's come back
to how you know he's how you know a
question is a binomial probability
question okay it's multistage well
that's fine
you got a peak finish it's no big deal
okay uh they need to be just two
outcomes that we're interested in or you
must be able to phrase it in some way so
there's only two outcomes what would
they be defect or not defect so no
problem okay ah but then in order to
make it work for binomial probability
you need every of them to be identical
but there's a problem with that all
right cuz when you open it up the box of
30 shirts and you pull one out you don't
know who made the shirt right so so you
don't know then which one of these will
take over okay so you're like how do i
how do I make the events
identical okay well you come back when
you pull one shirt part okay it's true
enough that you don't know well look at
that anatomical accuracy you don't know
who made the shirt huh but you know who
was likely to make the shirt and you
know how likely it was who made the
shirt because of course there are only
two options right it's either Josh or
it's fate okay now they make it at a
consistent rate so even though I don't
know whose shirt I actually pick up I
know that in a day how many shirts are
made in a day 50 shirts are made right
20 of them are joe's 20 out of 50 shirts
I chose right whereas the other 30
Affairs okay
there are we can come back to this idea
defect not defect right for each of them
they will either make a defective shirt
or not a defective shirt so you have
these options okay and we know the
probabilities for each one right for Joe
it's gonna be 2002 point nine eight
point four point nine six okay so now we
can come to try to build an identical
event we've got enough information now
okay we're interested in the defect
right
so looking at this situation right there
are only four kinds of shirts you can
pull out they're not all equally likely
clearly they're not all equally likely
right but you can know what their
probabilities up for instance what's the
probability of one of Joe's defense the
answer is well product rule 20 or 50
times pointer to 105 so you see you work
out that
and then you've got the probably that
phase will be a defense right and you
work that out okay so now the
probability of any single shirt being a
defect right so this is our identical
event which we can just repeat oh no no
Rach what it's gonna be well I have to
combine these do I add them or do I
multiply I must have clearly I must have
for a couple of reasons firstly if you
did what I did and you drew out a
probability tree right adding and
multiplication to only go in certain
ways multiplication goes along the
branches of a tree right whereas
addition goes up and down right does
that make sense so that's an easy
diagrammatic way where you can work out
which ones which in terms of logic you
can think about this way I'm pulling it
out how many shirts to look at them hold
on hold on just for this I'm pulling out
a single shirt right so who made this
shirt and the answer is Joe made it or
Fay made it but they didn't
simultaneously make the shirt right so
if they're not simultaneously I have to
add so the probability of Joe's defect
plus the probability of phase defect
okay now when you put that all together
I think you end up with 4 on 125 that's
our event yeah that's how probably no
event you could obviously work out what
the complement is which you'll need in a
second which will be there ok so now
I've set up my identical events and now
that binomial can unfold okay when you
have a look at this there are a few
different ways that this can happen
right there are a few cases what are the
cases give me one
no defects great do you are a defect
that's one way that we can satisfy this
okay there's another way one defense
again I'm adding these because a box
can't have zero defects and one defect
at the same time and then of course
there's one last case too because I I'm
okay with the boundary I am still no
more than two defects zero one or two
okay and then you work out each one in
turn how do we do the first one there's
three components right it's frickin
print how many ways are there to have no
defense the answer is 3 choose 0 right
that's how many ways and now I work out
the probability what's the probability
of a defect it's that but there aren't
any defects in the box so I do that zero
times and then I want all the other
shirts that's Betty to have no defense
you could recognize this in terms of the
general we developed this morning okay
and then you do the rest of the cases 30
choose one there's our one defect right
there the probability either 29 shirts
which are all good and their
probabilities and then your third and
last case two defense
twenty-eight good shirts okay you add it
all up and it's not that bad it's 93
percent roughly to the nearest percent
okay